good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Tuesday or as I like to
call it Tuesday cuz I'm making choices
today and one of those choices is to
spend the morning with my favorite girl
ISR on the planet it's Jackie let's see
how long I could talk before I let her
say a word
today it's my turn hey tury I love I
love that you feel you have a choice but
you don't have a choice but to spend
every morning with me Jackie there's
this little thing called Free Will and
if I wanted to like isn't it crazy both
you you and me both we both have the
power to just like [__] this [__] up and
be like listen I'm done with the toast
the thing is it's funny that we're
having this conversation today because
we literally don't like I'm sick as a
dog and I have no power to say like I'm
done with the toast today
like must go on like whenever I'm like
crossing the street I'm always like it's
amazing that like the car at the red
light has Free Will and isn't just going
to run me over like the way that we've
all just decided most of us to be
civilized is really amazing like I
always think I'm like I'm three Ines
from a car what is stopping this guy
from just killing me it's this Unwritten
social contract that we've all signed so
to be decent to one another you know
some of the time not most not all as
we've seen not on world kindness day
that's for sure certainly not but like
yeah you could just quit okay if I quit
like if you quit I would continue on and
I probably do it with Ben okay who would
you if I quit who would you do it with
Olivia Margo I see who wants the job
which one whoever wants the job where
maybe I'd make them audition maybe I'd
put it to a vote like could get really
testing them a be testing Q scores
screen testing screen testing the girls
okay that's a good answer okay
thanks you're welcome are you going
somewhere no no seems like you've given
this a lot of thought no no I am giving
a lot of thought always to just the
concept of free will do we have it sound
off in the comments I think that we do
what do you
think I think technically we
do un technically but human nature plays
A
Part yeah I mean
we still have a code of behavior and a
code of ethics that we all want to abide
by but it's our free will to engage in
those like yeah when I'm driving like I
could just run the red light and kill
some people but like I don't want to pay
the price of that and I also don't feel
like killing people you know right so
that's my human nature stepping in to
kind of trump my free will
yeah cool
yep just that's what I was thinking
about this morning when I was crossing
the
street maybe you didn't didn't think
that cuz you work from home um yeah so
you didn't you didn't like pass any cars
on your way to work today yeah and I
just know don't think about such dumb
[__] sometimes okay Free Will is not
dumb [__] [__] like it's maybe it's
because I just read the measure yeah I
actually think we had this conversation
I was trying to think if we've had it on
the toast or on the redheads when we
read the measure we were talking about
Free Will and all of us kind of chimed
in on like what our thoughts are about
Free Will so I don't know if that was
here or there but my thought is that
like I think we all have free will we
can make whatever decision that we want
but like God knows what decisions we're
going to make well yes that's true but
then you think about there are people
who literally do plow their cars into
crowds of people and maybe those people
like took the concept of free will like
too
crazy
yeah cuz that's really I can't I think
explanation I don't think that's what it
is that like their
fre just flipped I think that there's a
different code that they live by or
they're mentally ill yeah yeah okay so
maybe everything's not about Free Will
is what you're saying yeah there's just
more that goes into it
yeah okay um so this is a raging debate
that philosophers and uh theologians
have been having for centuries so you
know you and I kind of jumping in on a
random Tuesday like our experience and
our thoughts are valid no I'm saying but
you know we're just part of a larger
conversation okay and then it you know
then it makes me think of another larger
conversation nature vers nurture where
do you land on that Jack a bit of both
because and to me like that's always
been my thinking but then watching three
identical strangers proved that for me
like to me that settled the debate it's
a bit of Nature and a bit of nurture you
really can't talk about nature versus
nurture without bringing up three
identical strangers if you haven't seen
the documentary like you absolutely must
and the way like I just stumbled upon
that documentary on a Delta flight once
and then I like was texting everyone I
know and like Googling it they're like
yeah we all saw it two years ago that's
so me um and then made it my personality
and then found a personal connection to
the documentary if you guys wer in a
part of that era on the toast that was
so crazy literally three identical
strangers is are a Roman Empire yes it's
our Roman Empire like I was fully
convinced that Ben's mom was like a part
of this um like study that was done cuz
she was adopted it was it was uh the
same adoption agency like I never got
any proof but like I was just I made it
by myself yeah no you did have a very
clear connection to it I had a strong
case it wasn't a stretch by any means
considering like how you could have
stretched to make it about you you did
really didn't have to it was right there
I've done you know bigger back flips to
make it about myself 100% that was a
crazy time if you haven't watched three
identical strangers I would actually
that's one of the things I would say
turn off the toast and go watch it don't
wait till the episode is over like go
watch it now and then you know call your
local congressman and write your
representatives to get those papers
unsealed at Yale University not enough
people talk about like as long as we're
all talking about what's going on at
college campuses right now let's talk
about how Yale has sealed medical
documents about this incredibly [__]
up uh study experiment that was done on
real people without them knowing and
there are people walking around now who
don't even know they were a part of the
study because it all happened when they
were actual newborns and Yale University
has all that information and could
actually like reunite families and they
won't unseal it let's talk about that no
and it's like it won't be unsealed to
like 2080 or something everyone
participated would be dead also they ran
this medical experiment and in those
records are the results so it's like
okay you were tested on all these people
Liv you [__] up these people's lives
like what did you learn and there's so
much Anarchy going on on college
campuses and I'm not really one to
advocate for breaking the law but like
why not steal the records yeah I'm going
to steal the Declaration of Independence
we need Nicholas Cage up in this [__]
[__] steal the records okay I I'm
with Jack Jack has Ste why are these
records so protected like [__] steal
them there's no sense of
lawfulness Jack these college there's no
sense of Ethics right or wrong steal the
records okay Jackie if only Jewish
students were protected as swiftly and
as fiercely as these documents were well
you know that the documents are about
medical experiments that were on Jewish
children so they really don't give a
[__] about letting them out no but we're
just like actively living in the cover
up like we saw the documentary everybody
it blew the thing wide open and then in
2080 when these things come out we're
going to be like well why wasn't in like
2020 people still advocating while they
were alive to get the documents unsealed
so that's what I'm protecting my legacy
by having this conversation like I did
the right thing yeah no same and I feel
like it it you know it obviously moved
through the new cycle it's not top of
mind for anyone except for us and we
need to bring it back into the four I
know there's a lot going on in the world
but this is important we need to make
three identical Strangers Like Trend
again somebody needs to post about it on
Tik Tok you know how they like Tik Tok
they'll archival Center is overp party #
Yale is overp
party Yale's been overp party Yale will
always be overp
party so it's Tuesday we've got a show
that you know can't tell 100% but I'm
pretty sure it's going to be fabulous it
already is it always is that's the thing
but I feel like we have some things
working against us today like my
sickness Oh I thought you were going to
say
Free
Will no I wasn't you're worse I'm worse
than I was yesterday yes I'm hoping like
this is rock bottom and I start to get
better but between the coping sneezes
and nose blowing like I apologize in
advance I know it's annoying but imagine
how I feel imagine how I feel put
yourself in my shoes imagine how tired
we are of it imagine how tired we are of
it right so I do apologize I AP
apologize for the nasal she's slurring
she's sick she's sick but wait you know
what you might
need a nice warm chili to you know ease
the pain in your throat the Coes warm
the cockles of your heart and very
exciting Jackie and I been talking a lot
not actually a lot we've mentioned a few
times recently that we're doing like a
whole merch Rebrand new company new
website new everything and our first big
collection is set to come out in a few
weeks but a few days ago Jackie had this
like crazy idea for just a random merch
drop um and so last night we just put up
on our new website which is shop toast
merch.com um a collection of very chil
inspired items and it isn't like the big
new drop we've been talking about we
just like had this idea and we wanted to
get it up for pre-order um at shop toast
merch.com it's chili season merch
because it is that time of year we
needed to get it out we couldn't wait we
couldn't wait I was making my chili and
I was like I need merch to signify this
season of my life like I want to wear
this every Sunday while I'm whipping up
a chili and having a chili day right so
check that out the pictures are on our
Instagram but you can just go to shopto
merch.com to get a crew neck a hoodie or
a hat you can get whatever size you want
cuz it's available for pre-order so it's
not going to like sell out you can place
your order now it'll ship in about 3
weeks and you can get whatever you want
but that's not our big merch collection
that we've been teasing no no no no no
so just don't get confused and get
excited because what what we've been
teasing is really exciting and we will
continue to tease it and we've always
been teasing it and we always will be
teasing it if that ain't the truth so
how are the stories today the stories
are mediocre which I find sometimes an
added value because sometimes when we
have like fire stories we get we have to
talk about them you know what I mean
yeah like yesterday was very analytical
yeah yesterday was very like you know
here's what's going on in pop culture
when the stories are a little less then
we have to get creative yeah and that's
when we do our best work so so as I've
said I think it will be a great show
based on her track record if I was a
betting
woman but if history is any indicator
but you there's always a chance that
it's not there's always a chance and
you're right there are things working
against us yeah like the nasal is not my
best sound it's giving friend fine oh is
it yeah okay that makes it better like
she's very nasly that makes it better
have you ever seen the Nan of course oh
okay Nick at night baby yeah but you
never did like a rewatch right no no not
yet I I definitely would recommend it I
have so much on my content plate right
now so I started iron flame last night
I'm three pages in the new book the new
fourth Wing book yeah but I have to
lessons in chemistry which I'm watching
like with the people it's Episode by
episode I've heard the Buccaneers on
Apple TV was made I've heard it's
excellent I've heard it was made for me
yeah and I did see a commercial for it
and I thought this the same then I have
there was a series I was going to watch
I need to start writing these things
down I pretty much only have Gossip Girl
I watched three episodes last night me
and Ben turned to each other in the
middle and we were like this is the
greatest show ever made like to put it
simply it's
like there's never been a show that's
better really I thought you were going
to say the opposite like your time has
come to an end no no in the beginning it
definitely took a little like what is
this like it was a little cringe and I
like dragged it like last week we're at
the beginning of season 2 now it's just
simply
incredible great there's nothing better
brick for real now I know and then I
discovered last night because I forget
what we were talking
about we were just talking about shows
like Gossip Girl and I brought up the OC
and Ben's like I've never seen it so
that's what doing is such a good rewatch
I rewatched it recently especially for
Ben because Ben is Sandy Cohen oh my God
Claudia you need to start it like now I
know I forget that there's an element of
Judaism in the OC like you wouldn't
think you wouldn't honestly you need to
move on from Gossip Girl and S Ben's
never and he is Sandy Cohen Ben and
Sandy Cohen I couldn't believe oh
because we were talking about Len Meer
I'm like do you know who he's she's
married to now and he was like yes Adam
Brody and Ben's like what's he from and
I'm like oh he's Seth Co and he's like
who's Seth Co and I'm like have you
never seen the OC so that's how we got
to that conversation oh my God so that
that's like an exciting thing coming up
that is exciting wow yeah um so it's
just kind of been a lot about that
recently in my life I understand that's
good it's a good place to be how are the
boys are they sick did they get you sick
yeah Harry was the the culprit on this
one but I seem to be like sicker than he
was cuz it passed for him already so let
me ask you a question cuz I know a part
of being a mom is like just getting sick
because your kid gets sick at school
everybody's carrying around a bunch of
you know germs does it hit different
when you get sick from your kid it's
like it's like
better like anything har gives me we're
so we're so sympatico we're sick
together but to be honest most of the
sicknesses he's had like I'm already
immune to as an adult like he gets sick
cuz he's little and and getting
everything for the first time so it's
been a while since he gave me something
and this is just a common cold like it's
really nothing crazy it's just like so
inconvenient there's nothing to take for
it I can't even take a typical like cold
and sinus medication cuz I'm
breastfeeding and it will dry you out
because that's what it's meant to do
like dry out your sinuses it dries up
your supply okay but I would just
imagine that like any Harry comes over
and he gives me you know like a leaf
it's the most beautiful amazing Leaf
I've ever received in my life so I
imagine Harry comes over and gives me
the common cold like does it feel
different sure be honest no it feels the
same but it's nice to like be in it with
in the trenches with him mommy
understands yeah what you're going
through yeah and then I know like what
might be bothering him a little tickle
in the throat let's have an icy let's
have a Pedialite
icy that makes sense you know that
sounds good so I I get to like
experience it if he can't tell me his
symptoms I know you know mommy knows
mommy knows best mommy knows everything
and it's good if I get it because then I
get the antibodies of whatever it is and
I pass them onto Charlie so it's a whole
little ecosystem let me ask you another
question about motherhood because you
know they say like Mother Knows Best and
as you get older you realize like you
know everything you were told as a kid
like your parents were really always
right about everything so are you coming
into you're like you're now the person I
know on the authority who knows
everything yeah how does that feel and
where do you get your information that's
a great question I mean a lot of it I
think is like pass down from like what
your parents have done and like what
they would do when you were sick and
little like things but then I also see
some then also we go to the doctor we
learn more I see some stuff on the
internet like oh here's a little remedy
for tummy ache yeah but what I'm saying
is more like they always say like mommy
knows best they don't say like Daddy
knows best no fense so like you're like
what separates you from the pack of the
family as leader mother's intuition
mother's that's true it it is real it is
yes
100% it's very real and that's just
biological cuz I've seen you become that
and that's on God
literally cuz I've seen you become that
you know even in our own even as it
pertains to me you know like I just kind
of defer to you like you've really just
become that person it doesn't happen
overnight it's like a slow transition
yeah it doesn't happen overnight but
it's just a wisdom acquired over time
that's beautiful coupled with Mother's
intuition like I just feel like when the
day comes God willing I should be so
lucky to be a mother like I'm not going
to be like a smart one like I'm still
like like dumb do you know what I mean I
know what you're saying cuz are there
moms out there serious question who are
dumb
yes okay and I was just thinking that
like not every mother at the outset has
all this wisdom I think a lot of it is
learning on the job you know your K gets
sick once and then the next time you are
more prepared yeah so it's a wising up
over time but you're not dumb like
you're not a dumb woman no like other
women might be Jackie like I am like I'm
really like not smart when it comes to
like common sense like I think I'm very
business savvy I think I'm smart in you
know different and unique ways but when
it comes to like I find myself like the
answer to like obvious things are always
like right in front of most people and
they're like never in front of me do you
know what I mean yeah I mean every once
in a while I do something incredibly
dumb okay that makes me feel better and
I'm like oh I'm so I'm so dumb like I
think I'm smart and I'm just a dummy
okay that that's a universal experience
is that what you're saying yeah like I
I'll do something and I'm
like who gave me like I wish I could
think of an example but it's like no
like like the answer is so obvious and
it didn't even cross my mind yeah no I
wish I could I feel like something is on
the tip of my tum of something I did
recently that was like dumb Common Sense
oh I mean I guess like when you rolled
your ankle like you shouldn't have
walked through the weeds of grass you
should have just walked on the sidewalk
yeah I was thinking that
too but just like dumb stuff even when
it comes to like cooking like sometimes
I'll put my hand on something that's
like viously hot no that's so meated
like totally like oh you know what I
kind of I have like a I have a cooking
hack for everyone okay I guess a lot of
people do this but like we don't because
we keep coacher but like at Costco and a
million grocery stores they sell just
like a road history chicken that's
already cooked so like you just heat it
up and that's literally dinner yeah so I
was on instacart yesterday and I saw
that Fairway had a kosher one yeah
dinner I literally made dinner Ben was
shoke I'm like I made dinner oh so that
the cook kacos to buy a rotisserie
chicken yeah even though like I know
everybody knows that but like we haven't
really been able to participate in that
no it's true we don't get to participate
in and then I think the next level of
that is like when you use the rotisserie
chicken from the store and like make a
chicken pot pie so Ben does that with um
chicken salad he's like a rotisserie so
when I got oh this is insane I literally
was so excited I like made dinner Ben
got home late he was podcasting he went
on um chicks in the office and like they
went on him so good guys chicks in the
office collab was it both of the boys
well so the chicks in the off the chicks
are in La I saw they were at dear media
Studios were they doing good guys yes
but so like Ben was like the loser on
the remote end of it and he like
honestly that never works out I'm sorry
it doesn't I don't think so either
that's why the gires and Josh were like
kiking hard and Ben was like loserville
Central in sitting in this chair right
here um what was the point where was I
go oh so he gets home and I like was so
generous I got this rotisserie chicken
bless
you let it out girl put it in the book I
put my mic across the room okay
hopefully that helps but you can hear me
right my rotisserie chicken story it's
really interesting um so Ben gets home
and he's like oh rotisserie chicken so
I'm like yeah I made some rice Ben was
going to like make some veggies and I
was like that's dinner like so easy you
know and he's like no I think I'm going
to shred this up and make chicken salad
I'm like ex like I was personally offend
I'm like first all I bought this for us
so we could like have dinner for you to
then take the that I bought that I spent
time on time Rec sourcing sourcing and
then take it away from me and tear it up
for your nasty [__] chicken salad he
couldn't understand why I was like so
deeply offended by that yeah it's
offensive because it was your idea it
was your rotisserie chicken yes and he's
making something that you don't eat like
he could make a chicken pot pie with it
and that would be better I wouldn't eat
that okay um chicken
soup I'm not sick you understand what
I'm saying right Chen
casserole okay whatever the [__] you eat
yeah okay okay he if he had made
something that was like tury friendly
something that you've been dying for
like that's a good use of the chicken
but to just be so selfish and unkind on
world kindness day I on world kindness
day nonetheless I knew you would
understand yeah so did he use the whole
chicken or like half of it his portion I
literally said sit down we're having
rotisserie chicken for dinner and that's
what we have and you said you'll eat it
you'll EAD it and you'll like it that's
exactly what I said well maybe I am a
mother maybe like I feel like as you're
entering your homemaking ERA this is
preparing you because now you have
dinner on the table okay sure you have
to do it seven nights a week every day
for the rest of your life maybe that's
why God made men so dumb and incapable
to prepare this is obviously a
heteronormative way of thinking so
pardon my my heteronormativity my
exclusivity but maybe God made men so
[__] stupid and incapable so that by
the time we get married you're married
for maybe a year two years 3 years in my
case seven before you have children so
you're prepared for that sort of
immaturity and toddler esik Behavior
it's true but some men well first of all
your husband is I refuse to believe it
that some men are smart no that some men
are like capable who do I don't mean
like smart as in like wisdom I mean like
you know chores meals cleanup household
things
books and thank God for that like your
husband is an actual Chef okay yes and
while that's lovely to have like a you
know a cocoon for dinner but what about
the like the dishes Ben made literally
okay Ben last night made just like
roasted onions and carrots we just had
like some stuff so we had a veggie not
onions like carrots potatoes whatever
four
dishes four like four pots and pans he
needs an OPD a one pot dish but like to
Ben if if he's not making enough dishes
like it's not enough of a meal do you
know mean doesn't feel like he's really
cooking yeah I understand that also
that's a theory I have what I was also
thinking it's like when Zach and like
right now I'm like such a homemaker like
I try and cook something every single
day I had fresh muffins in my house like
I'm just you're in that era I'm that
woman but when Zach and I were dating
like if he was looking for a homemaking
wife like it would not have been me like
I remember one time I was like I'm going
to cook dinner for him at my apartment
like do something special whatever
Olivia made the whole meal and the thing
that like I was in charge of I think it
was like just chopping a salad like took
me forever to chop and it's like if you
had you really don't know what you're
going to get when you when you are with
someone young and then I mean look at
how I've blossomed but like it's true
you would have never expected this from
me I'm so glad you brought up a salad
cuz like the absolute one time I ever
cooked for Ben while we were dating he
was like we were together and he
randomly like wanted a salad I was like
oh okay I was like let me make it and
like to this day he still talks about
the salad so I like cut up so good no I
cut up I don't really like I don't eat
salad so like I don't really know what
goes in a salad you know it on your
preference and it depends what you have
in the fridge yeah so I put salad in
lettuce I cut up carrots but like they
were baby carrots so they were just
these kind of like really weird circles
yeah that's hard to eat amongst other
things then I put um hearts of pomm in
it love which Ben doesn't like okay he's
wrong for that and then like I know Ben
loves dressing and he loves sauce so
like I just put Russian on top that's
pretty and to this day like he still
talks about the salad like I could see
the salad in my head like the round
little carrots it was not my finest
moment the thing about salads is that
they're typically like you have to go
with a Vibe like you have to select your
salad and then that will dictate the
ingredient choose your players so if you
wanted to do obviously a Caesar salad
you should have done that cuz it's just
like lettuce cheese and croutons and buy
all those things or if you want to do
like a Greek salad that tells you what
the ingredients feta onion Olive
cucumber yeah yum I I do a bit of mix
and match but when you're making your
salad for yourself you could do whatever
the hell you want it basically sounds
like what you're saying is salad is
personal salad is
personal um so I feel like we've
dilly-dallied long enough and perhaps
perhaps it's time for the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you need to know
are brought to you by L'Oreal this
episode of the toast is brought to you
by the new L'Oreal Paris bright revealed
dark spot serum and the broadspectrum
SPF 50 daily lotion dark spots game over
after summer I feel like we all took a
look in the mirror and we were like wow
we did not protect our skin enough we
have dark spots we have a little bit of
sun damage and L'Oreal is here for you
so the L'Oreal Paris bright reveal dark
spot serum visibly Fades all types of
dark spots up to 40% after 12 WE 12
weeks you can see up to 40% less VIs
visibility on post acne marks 43% less
visibility on dark spots and 49% more
even tone it starts fading in just one
week even the most stubborn dark spots
and after two weeks your skin will look
clearer your skin texture will look
refined and smooth it's made for all
skin tones it's suitable for sensitive
skin it's formula is validated by
dermatologist and why don't you stop
dark spots before they even start we
have to wear SPF ladies we're not 14
anymore you know under your makeup every
day you're going out you need to be
wearing SPF not me like yelling at
everyone when I don't even like I'm not
even good with my SPF
what's what I'm looking for consistency
but the L'Oreal spf50 daily UV lotion is
a stick it makes it so easy it doesn't
leave a white cast that's why for so
long I was like I'm not putting this on
it's making me look pale you can visibly
reduce the appearance of dark spots and
resist sun-induced signs of aging with
this product the daily UV lotion 100% of
dark spots are intensified by are
intensified by the Sun and 96% of women
agree that this product does not leave a
white cast so discover the new bright
revealed dark spot Duo visit Target
online and in store to buy yours today
that's Target the bright reveal dark
spot Duo from L'Oreal Paris today's
episode is also brought to you by ag1 if
you are tired of taking so many
supplements and want a single solution
that supports your entire body and
covers your nutritional bases every day
if you want better gut health a boost in
energy immune system support and you
hate taking pills and vitamins but you
want a supplement that actually tastes
great start drinking ag1 you will feel a
real real difference in your daily
Health you also will have more energy
and you will notice a more relaxed feel
and a better focus no one is about a
spokesperson for ag1 who literally got I
was up later than b today he sat on my
bedside chugging his ag1 he's made it
his entire personality um but really
there are so many benefits especially if
you just want to be more how do I say
this nicely have better digestive
consistency and health it'll really get
you on a good track you there's nothing
better I'm sorry than making like a big
dump in the morning I'm sorry and ag1 is
just great for that it really is it is a
Supple supplement that we trust to
provide the support our body needs daily
and that's why we're excited to partner
with them and welcome them in as a new
partner so if you want to take ownership
of your health it starts with ag1 try
ag1 and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D D3 K2 and five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink a1.com toast that's drink A1 the
number
one.com toast check it out Ben will be
mad at me if I don't give him credit for
like putting me on the ag1 train um
Olivia Ash too but really Ben has
brought into our home oh and sitch we're
family yeah today's episode is also
brought to you by Thrive Market we
always love a Black Friday deal but what
we really love is a Black Friday deal on
groceries did you see that Meme it's
like this Black Friday put the eggs on
sale like that's what people need just
everything to be normal priced yeah for
their every day I don't need a flat
screen TV I have right we were saying we
need grocery back Friday and Thrive
Market was like hi we do that black Frid
uh Thrive Market was like wait hold my
eggs we're excited that thrive Market is
having a Black Friday and Cyber Monday
sale Thrive Market is our go-to for all
of our grocery and household essentials
the convenience of getting everything
online and then quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge gamees timesaver and
Game Changer Thrive Market as a member
we save money on every single grocery
order on average we're saving over 30%
every time and with their Black Friday
and Cyber Monday sale we are going to be
saving even more we're getting 30% off
thousands of Thrive Market favorites so
you know we'll be stocking up for me the
snacks like I'm I was actually on the
phone with Jackie yesterday asking her
what she gets from Thrive Market because
I really have been very conscious of
keeping like good healthy snacks in my
house so I don't get super hungry and
then just have a big meal or get super
hungry and eat crap yeah so so I like
shopping from th market like I love
Annie's I love their cheese puffs like I
got really good recommendations from you
and from th market for good things just
to have in my house to keep me on my
journey yes they also have great food
options for babies and toddlers And they
have such great health stuff I actually
have a package that's being delivered
like today I got like a ton of
beekeepers natural because we're all
sick and I'm really excited to incorp at
those into our immunity boosting get an
extra 30% off Thrive Market members
items favorites during their Black
Friday and Cyber Monday sale plus new
members can stack on the savings with
30% off their first order plus a free
$60 gift take advantage of the Black
Friday and cyber monday deals by going
to thrivemarket.com theeast and new
members save 30% off your first order
plus a free $60 gift that's t r i v
market.com thet toast thrivemarket.com
theet toast thank you la you're welcome
fa our first store some big divorce news
the Big D the Big D Chris Appleton files
for divorce from Lucas Gage after 6
months of marriage according to La
divorce documents obtained by people
Chris cited irreconcilable differences
on Monday with the date of Separation as
November 10th the documents also show
that a postnuptial agreement is in place
Chris Appleton who is a hair stylist to
the Stars namely Kim Kardashian married
Lucas Gage in a Las Vegas ceremony on
April 22nd with Kim officiating the
episode just aired on the Kardashian of
honestly I feel like he was
contractually obligated to stay married
until that episode aired like the timing
is crazy the timing is crazy I don't
know about a contract but it would been
really weird to watch an episode of
people getting married who are already
divorced so I just felt like for their
reputation like let's just wait a few
days until the episode airs yeah I I
honestly feel like this was the weirdest
Saga I don't think this shocks anyone
the only somewhat surprising thing about
this is the timing um like the shortness
or because of the episode because the
episode no the shortness we knew I think
we were all just like waiting for the
day that we heard like they literally
dated for a I think maybe a month like
it was crazy and then they went to Vegas
and got married like it was so cliche
almost I know but sometimes when that
happens I'm like it's love at first
sight you hear people's like
grandparents that this happens all the
time Jackie we're not living in those
types of times we for six weeks and now
we've been together 60 years no that's
sweet but that [__] like that doesn't
happen anymore I like I want to believe
in a world where it does so when I saw
thought they were so serious so fast and
then they take it to getting married for
me that makes me believe I believe I
Believe in a Thing Called Love that's
really I Believe in a Thing Called Love
that's sweet I didn't especially cuz
they got married like if they didn't get
married and they just got hot and heavy
really fast you know like Pete and
Ariana style fine you know burn bright
fizzle out fine but to get married I'm
like give me 60 years I just think about
all the people whose wedding songs are
sh
Twain and who would have done anything
to have Shia Twain perform at their
wedding you know yes that is true and it
just seems unfair honestly because that
song Still the One is literally a
classic it's up there with like you know
Ed Sheeran uh it's up there with Oh What
a Wonderful World oh The Way You Look
Tonight Like thousand years it was
Jackson Britney's wedding song I was out
there wedding you know I'm sure they
would have loved to have Shia perform it
for them yeah you know what it makes me
think of even though it wasn't a Shania
Twain song
okay that love is blind couple that was
obsessed with that lean Ryme song I Hope
You
Dance uh Bliss and Zach Bliss and Zach
Honestly Love is Blind really should
have gotten her at least they got the
rights to the song it's not Leanne ryes
it's Leanne wac okay close enough it's
true at least they got the rights to the
song you know they're like cheap about
licens yeah but the song was such a big
part of the season and like the memes
they splurged so they weren't going to
splurge for Le herself I don't know I I
think Le wack these days like wouldn't
be crazy pricey yeah and Bliss and Zach
are still together they are so are
Chelsea and
quame so that's why it's like shocking
that Chris and Lucas couldn't make it
like other couples
have gone the distance so are Amber and
Barnett that doesn't surprise me no but
now CH andw and Bliss and Zach their
road to marriage was so Rocky and their
seasons were so awkward it's surprising
but Amber and Barnett like love they
were strong yeah they were strong just
like Lauren and Cameron no I'm actually
more shocked probably the most shocked
by Chelsea and guame than I am over
anyone else even though like Bliss and
Zach were so untraditional and so like
fast in the boat and the other girl like
what was her name Arena like I get it
but to me Chelsea and kwami were more
shocking because just based on the
footage it so appeared like they didn't
like each other no that he didn't like
her he don't yeah and that's just like
the basis of you know a marriage is
likeness but the fact that they're still
together is proof in the pudding no it
makes me really question what we see on
the shows yes yes like that was bad them
being together is bad for the editors
cuz it's like hey we're a bunch of
[__] Liars yeah or maybe some people
are just not good at showing affection
especially with cameras in your face and
maybe that's what kwami's dealing
with I don't know the way it made it
seem was like he would have chosen Micah
that scene in the pool
that's seen in the pool it's so crazy
how these people get so famous and
recognizable for 30 seconds like when
you just said mik I'm like wait who is
that yeah it's really just a flash in
the pad yeah Zach is obsessed with Love
is Blind he's recently been he watched
like the most recent season and that's
or with you by himself but I would like
look over his shoulder a little bit like
you know what Olivia and Shapiro are
also obsessed with it too it's kind of
like Elder millennial that's like who
watches Love is Blind then he went back
and watch Jackie is Love is Blind
cheoy yeah yeah then he went back and
watched every season that he hadn't seen
already and oh he has to watch the first
season he needed even more and he
started watching the
ultimatum oh my God is he okay he's
obsessed he's like just in this era of
dating shows don't tell him about the
bachelor no you got him you're to blame
because he obviously just loved love
Island yeah but I don't know why he
started watching that scene Season of
Love is Blind I'm sure that like he
heard oh we watched the last season
together that was like in the spring I
remember that was like cir clera and we
we watched like the live finale together
so yeah I got him into it and then he
like couldn't get enough that's so funny
and also that's great news because our
list of things to watch for our holiday
trip this year as a family is the golden
Bachelor so he'll be on board he'll love
it yeah and those shows are so funny
when you watch them with like a big
group yeah and I've heard golden match
is really good me too I'm really trying
not to spoil it I haven't I have only
seen that Jerry said he found his match
Gary
Gary I just feel like it's not right
that it should be Jerry like it's just
I'm sure it's a family name and it's
beautiful but like if you're going to go
on TV like your name's got to be Jerry I
just feel like once we start watching
we'll get used to Gary yeah and we'll be
like oh I can't believe we ever called
him Jerry but until we get there it's
like Jerry by the way have any of of the
golden Bachelor contestants had old
tweets or are they like beyond that I
don't know I I haven't seen anything at
this point like there isn't a reality
show that pops off without one
contestant having like old tweets yeah
something old liked photos right right
so like did anybody dox the golden
Bachelor Queens yet I don't know but
don't give them any ideas Claude sorry I
was just curious are you ready for our
next story cuz it's some more divorce
news oh my God
no one's getting divorced today okay
Lisa Hawkin is launching an amicable
divorce company amid her brutal spit
from Lenny So Lisa Hawkin is ready to
help others who are headed for divorce
she is launching uh a service called
split well which is a service to help
EST strange couples end their marriages
amicably and quote without breaking the
bank a Bravo fan account posted about
the reality star's new Endeavor which
Lisa then reposted to her stories and
said turning my pain into purpose the
website isn't fully functional yet but
inquiring minds can add their names to
the wait list for more information it
also notes that it's powered by
AI question question mark okay I I mean
this is like a nice idea I have to
imagine if this was possible like
somebody would have done it before this
isn't like a unique idea like I don't
know she's dating like a tech Mogul like
maybe they're about to oh that's true
maybe they're about to like re solve
divorce it's giving Christine Quinn also
it's like what if it's a an app where
two people are getting divorced they
they type into the thing it's powered by
AI so you type in like what you want in
the divorce the other person types in
too and AI comes up with something that
maybe you both could live with so it's
basically like a digital
mediator cuz that's a part of that's a
part of divorce proceedings sitting down
with a mediator we don't know what this
is I'm just
guessing yeah I love you know turning
your pain into purpose I think that's
beautiful I love that there's you know a
tech Mogul behind this I that's hopeful
just a guess it doesn't say that
anywhere we didn't get much except for a
screenshot it says divorce made
dignified join us or sign in and it says
coming soon breaking up without breaking
the bank powered by AI join the I do not
agree that this is giving Christine
Quinn like towards the end Sunset when
she was just becoming like digital
realtor girl with her Tech Mogul Silicon
Valley husband yeah and they were doing
like Bitcoin purchased homes also that's
another really underrated thing
Christine Quinn is married yeah do you
know what I mean yeah for a long time
now she just like came back one season
with a boyfriend and then got engaged
got married on TV and like they're
literally married yeah their wedding was
unbelievable yeah like that was so
Random she has a child
yeah and a business yeah I haven't heard
much about her app but I'm not big in
the what's it called not Bitcoin crypto
coin cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency so I wouldn't know
Bitcoin is a cryptocurrency yes yes it
is like I think the the most popular one
but I look forward to hearing what this
is I like my idea for it yeah yeah yeah
because like maybe that maybe like
imagine if AI could solve divorce like
you put in the things that you
absolutely have to have you put in the
things that you want things you could
live without and they generate a
solution as a society where did we land
on AI cuz I remember like the
conversations bad bad bad but then maybe
good like where do we land so here's
where we're Landing I think because I
saw a commercial by the way for a
company and they were like saying and
we're powered by AI like as if it was
like we're carbon neutral like a good
thing yeah so here's where we're going
to land AI is an amazing technical
advancement it's going to make a lot of
things more automated and easy even in
my daily life I've started using AI for
some things and it's [__] hysterical
yeah um but it's going to be the end of
us okay it will be the end of
civilization as we know it if we can't
Rainer in but here's my question can AI
be
funny I guess it's how you define funny
like how genuinely genuinely
funny you know what I mean yeah cuz I
forget what I was thinking I might use
AI for but I was like could AI be really
funny
okay I'm going to ask AI to tell me a
joke which AI do you use
chpt yeah I'm going to blow my nose oh
log in oh my God yeah just make an
account Claud it's the future I think I
did that's the thing oh look my iPad has
something saved so log in let's use a
strong password
whatever continue so I'm just going to
be like AI oh God I have to verify my
email this is such a torturous Endeavor
it it'll be worth it for the really
funny joke AI is going to wrate us oh
yeah this better be good where's oh here
open your email
verify
email verified
okay oh tell us about you leave me alone
like to me I'm still so surprised when
AI isn't just like ask
jees literally oh they want my phone
number too what nerve they want I mean
this is what I mean it's going to be the
end of us now I need a code oh my God
I'm definitely like selling my soul to
the devil 100% don't forget your
fingerprint by the way we will we're
literally watching the demise of tury
right now tury is selling her soul for a
joke just get me to the
chat okay okay let's go tell me a joke
and then maybe we could ask a to tell a
joke about something specific why don't
scientists trust
Adams I don't know because they make up
everything oh that's not bad okay say
tell me a joke
about what do you want like to hear a
joke about Taylor Swift
o
why did Taylor Swift bring a ladder to
the bar because she heard drinks were on
the house see that's just taking a joke
and putting Taylor Swift's name in it
true true okay so let's say tell me a
joke
about I had
one or say write me a com a standup
comedy
special write me a I like
that a standup write me standup
comedy about some about being a woman
about being a woman love that AI needs
Direction they're not mind readers yet
sure let's give it a shot you know being
a woman is like being a part of a secret
society we have this unspoken code like
if I see another woman struggling with
her outfit in a public restroom it's an
immediate call to action we become
fashion superheroes offering spare bobby
pins sharing emergency deodorant and
delivering pep talks like girl you rock
that jumpsuit but let's talk the ma talk
about the magical world of handbags this
is like so insulting to women seriously
my purse is like Mary Poppins bag it
contains everything I could possibly
need in any given situation need a
tissue lipstick Band-Aid I've got you
covered it's like a survival kit
disguised as a fashion accessory this is
really bad it's bad but like and ladies
can we talk about the multitasking
skills we can all hold the conversation
send a text and plot world domination
all while getting ready for a night out
okay it's giving Netflix it's giving
Netflix female driven comedy okay that's
crazy me an episode of the
toast
podcast yeah but that is crazy like
someone could get on stage and do that
like I wouldn't laugh but oh my God
wait what I think they they think we're
talking about toast
oh yeah literally it's velvety it's
smooth avocado poached egg okay good
that means they can't do our job yet
love that we'll have to keep checking
every few
weeks who is Claudia
Ash they heard who is chy
Lou as my last knowledge updated in
January 2022 Claudia ashre is a social
media personality comedian and author
known for her online presence on under
the moniker girl with no
job wait she gained popularity from her
humorous posts and memes on Instagram
and other platforms firms Claudia along
with her sister Jackie Olivia Margo has
been involved in creating content and
building a brand around their unique
personalities please note that
information about individuals can change
and there might have been developments
in Claud as's career and personal life
since my last update
recomend is Claudia ashre married well
that's an easy Google search you're
you're lowballing
AI she was married to Ben safer who is
known on social media as boyf no job
they got engage in 2017 and their
wedding took place in September member
2019 that's not right no that's not
right okay I'm impressed yeah no that
was interesting interesting exercise um
our next I sold my soul for that our
next story speaking of the future
speaking of technology and speaking of
the future without technology Lauren
Sanchez is looking to the Future in a
new Vogue spread so Lauren Sanchez
fiance of Jeff Bezos is getting the
Vogue treatment she did a sit down
interview with Vogue a shoot with any
leitz and a couple or one one photo that
I saw with Jeff and Jeff's
bicep um yeah I had just started reading
the interview a little bit but it's
every time I read something about her or
engage with her content it just it's
always so striking like how normal she
is like she's saying you know she was
she blacked out when he proposed like we
all did you know yeah yeah I was shook
to see these two they're a a a very
unique level of celebrity where he is
you know a very famous business
person um he's kind of a part of this
very exclusive category of billionaires
yeah but he's kind of bigger than
probably any billionaire not even in
terms of money but in terms of like
cultural impact you know Amazon and then
she's just this kind
of nobody at first and they were like
you know Martin Scandal and now they're
coming out on the other side like so
normal and very famous with you know the
Kardashians and the marel like it's so
weird yeah and now they're just like
doing the circuit I guess you know when
you're engaged to je basos you can do
whatever you want cuz if they didn't put
her in Vogue like he would buy the
magazine right um and I I like you know
using your power for thirst I do oh
don't get me like if I was Lauren
Sanchez I would be doing the exact same
thing hanging out with and Megan hanging
out with the Kardashians being on Vogue
like she's so relatable it's disgusting
like oh I'm Marrying the most powerful
man in the world there's nothing I can't
get I want to be on the cover of Vogue
yeah so she was taking pictures all
around their like blue origin compound
in Texas she's in a helicopter she is a
former helicopter pilot wow yeah she was
a newscaster then a helicopter pilot wow
and now a philanthropist lady of leisure
Mrs Jeff Bezos uh literally I want my
Tombstone to read she was a
philanthropist comma lady of leisure Mrs
B offer Mrs
Bezos watch out
Lauren um some of the pictures are
really stunning some of them are like
not my my absolute favorite in terms of
artistic Direction but it's a very great
shoot I follow her on Instagram now
because of convers the like there's not
a lot there but we had a conversation
about her I followed her while we were
sitting in these chairs because I was
like I want to know what she's about and
like there's a lot of like you know
clean water philanthropy but that's how
I saw about this shoot and she's so
hyped about it I'm so happy for her you
know this is this is a girl who would
I'm sorry never be in
Vogue as a newscaster slh helicopter
reporter um so this is just exciting to
see someone get in Vogue who you know if
Circumstances had been different
wouldn't be in Vogue so I'm I'm very
happy for her yeah I hope she does the
podcast yes talks about life with Jeff I
think she's literally going to do a
reality show next oh lit like that's
what I'm saying it's it's just giving
like
accessibility you know it's giving like
I'm going to do what I want because I
can yeah and you would think like some
people in her position their position
like you know are extremely private not
into like the fame and just take
themselves so seriously and they're like
no we're going to have fun with this
life that we have and we're going to
have an engagement party on a yacht and
Leo's going to be there and all these
celebrities and like
and that's what we were just saying
about Taylor like if you make it to this
level of success and you're not enjoying
yourself what are you doing and what's
McKenzie up to she remarried I think
divorced oh yeah she gave away all her
money couldn't be me mcken Bezos would
be Bezos I also confuse her with Melinda
Gates no they're so different to me they
divorce most
okay yeah she married someone else for 2
years
and gave all her money away right well
she does the giving pledge so now she's
you know broke and alone no I'm kidding
no the giving pledge like you're still
fine that was like so crazy how she got
36 million billion dollar right that's
how much it was she has an estimated net
worth of 27 billion so that was just H
like I'm not really a jealous person no
I totally am but I don't think I think
that might be the most jealous I've ever
been of someone
like she did it right she married a nerd
she made a nice life with him that's why
you go for the Nerds you guys because
they'll give you $27 billion at some
point yeah I don't know it doesn't
always work out like that like
don't nerds sometimes nerds become
successful and like they think they're
too good for like the girl who loved
them when they were a nerd do you not
think that's what happened
here no I don't actually why cuz were
together for a really really long time
after his success it wasn't like he got
successful you know who I do feel like
that about and I I know you love him
Elon no oh I can't even begin to get
into elon's personal love life it's I
don't even know what's going on it's so
confusing I feel that way about Robert
herc feel like he was always very
wealthy but then he got like famous
Shark Tank Dancing with the Stars and he
ran away with his dancing with the star
like I feel bad for the girl who married
married Robert you know OG Robert but do
you not feel like the proof is in the
pudding with Robert and Kim I'm not
denying their love or their but I I
think you know we need to talk about you
know the women who made these men who
they are and then got left behind yeah
but as long as they are like
appropriately con compensated for their
time and their Vision that's like let's
talk about the girl Elon first married
and had five kids with yeah we don't
even know her name and I'm sure she's
well taken care of Elon is notorious for
taking care of all the mothers of all of
his children um you know there's a lot
of speculation that Amber herd's child
is Elon and that you know he paid for
all of her lawyers during that like so
they're all well taken care of I just
think we need to for talk about some of
the Forgotten women yeah Justine musk
2000 to
2008 right five kids eight years but he
started PayPal which was when I don't
know early 2000s okay then Tula Riley
2010 to 2012 and then Tula Riley again
2013 to 2016 that's so Elon that's
literally what's happening right now
with him in Grimes they're like on and
off but see like and this is where Elon
and Jeff Bezos differ and I think why
you and I really um are like into Lauren
and Jeff is Jeff is very stable like
elon's like such a genius they're both
Geniuses because they both started
companies that change the world Elon is
that sort of like crazy genius and Jeff
gives very you know stable homebody
energy yeah because he's found the right
girl like feel like maybe Elon hasn't
maybe that's what he needs you the right
girl
snitch Lauren Sanchez is in Vogue happy
for her never thought I'd see the day
when I was reading those text messages I
want to get a little drunk if You' have
told me honestly I would have believed
it you would have I wouldn't have I
thought those text messages were going
to end them those were but that's the
thing we were just saying that like when
something is happening in real time when
it comes to like a scandal you you think
it's just like the biggest deal in the
world and it's really it's never that
big of a deal it's just a blip yeah and
if you're going through something right
now I feel like that could be like a
good message not you don't have to be a
celebrity like you're always thinking
when you're going through something like
this is the biggest deal in the world
and then years later you're like oh yeah
that thing that happened that small
thing right and you're actually grateful
some of the time yeah oh my gosh am I
getting you sick through the computer
did you kiss me through the phone I'm
giving you a virus ooh sexy you need um
Norton's
antivirus I do on your computer are we
about to do the fourth story we're about
to do the fourth story so please expel
yourself the fourth story that's brought
to you by zi recter perhaps yes there
are so many people in your life that you
are grateful for it if you run a
business the people that you work with
I'm sure you're so grateful for them
because it really is a team that makes
the dream work I believe that's the
phrase Teamwork Makes the Dream Work and
for us it takes a team of people to make
the show successful just like it takes a
solid team to make make any business
successful so if you're hiring how do
you find the best people for your team
one word zip recruiter right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast and here's why
you'll be grateful that you tried zip
recruiter for your hiring they're
matching technology it's unmatched if
you will zip recruiter uses smart
technology to scan thousands of resumes
to find the most qualified people for
your job great match notifications so
zip recruiter lets you find the most
qualified people for your job and they
are a great match for it when they are a
great match for it it will encourage
them to apply they also do the invite to
apply which is great you can use this
ZIP recruiter feature to easily send a
personal invite to apply to top
candidates so they're more likely to
apply see why so many businesses and
business owners and hiring managers are
thankful for zip recruiter you know it's
Thanksgiving what are you thankful for
I'm thankful for zip recruiter four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day I'd be super grateful if
you go to the exclusive link of
ziprecruiter.com toast to try zi
recruiter for free again that's zip
recruiter.com /
T to try zip recruiter for free ZIP
recruiter the smartest way to hire
today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer's dog the results of
switching your dog food from kibble to
Fresh can seem like magic when a senior
dog dog starts acting like a puppy again
and the pickiest of eaters can't wait
for dinner time you might think some
spells were cast but the farmer's dog
doesn't use any sorcery or secret
ingredients to make their food fresh
they just use science so the farmer's
dog makes and delivers Health fresh
healthy dog food it's developed by bets
it's nutritionally balanced and it's
made from real healthy ingredients to
human food safety conditions it's the
best option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canned
goo it's just real healthy food
traditional wet and dog dry dog food
options are highly processed they can
use much lower quality ingredients than
they claim to and they're extremely
difficult to portion accurately so the
farmer's dog is fresh healthy dog food
it gets delivered to your house
pre-portioned so you know exactly how
much to give your dog you will see
immediate benefits like a shinier coat
more energy more consistent and you know
more consistently timed and sized poops
dogs at any age have enormous benefits
from the farmer's dog Theo being one of
them his breath is so much better so it
doesn't matter if your dog is young or
old it's always the right time to begin
investing in their health helping you
live more healthy happy and full years
together that means more magical moments
with your dog but no act actual magic is
required get 50% off your first box of
fresh healthy food at thefarmersdog.com
toast plus you get free shipping when
you go to thefarmersdog.com toast
that's
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free shipping today's
episode is also brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place all on your own
terms so whatever reasons you might have
for wanting to start a website whether
it's a side hustle you work in
e-commerce it can be really daunting and
I feel like a lot of people think it's
really expensive you have to hire like a
big fancy firm you have to be a computer
science engineer no you just need
Squarespace they've got tons of product
features like an asset Library so you
can upload organize and access all your
content in one place if you're a
photographer or videographer who wants a
website to Showcase their portfolio if
you want to sell custom merch you can
easily sell custom merch and create
passive income streams that engage your
audience and scale your brand what I
love most about Squarespace is that so
many people use Squarespace and their
websites for e-commerce but they also
have a point of sale so if you want to
sell online you also want to go to a
trade show or sell in person you can
easily sell in person by connecting a
square reader to the Squarespace app
it'll keep your orders and your
inventory data all in sync with your
online store so it's just one place with
all of your invoices all of your
purchase history all of your customer
data there's a million reasons you could
want to start a website obviously
e-commerce is a big one so that's a
great asset you can also just Showcase
Video collections they've got really
flexible website templates so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% % off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain thank you la you're
welcome fa our next story an hathway
says she was warned that her career
would fall off a cliff at the age of 35
which a lot of women face so an hathway
is 41 years old which means she has long
toi W she looks great yeah she has long
toi the warning she often heard as a
teen actor that her career would not
flourish past a certain age in Hollywood
she said when I started out as a child I
was warned that my career would fall off
a cliff at the age of 35 which is
something I know a lot of women face the
thing that has evolved during that time
is that more women are having careers
deeper into their life which I think is
fantastic obviously it doesn't mean we
should have a tick or tape parade
someone said this to me the other day
there's so much to be proud of and
there's so much to fix she said okay go
off an go it's such a sweet feeling to
know that you're kind of woven into
someone's life through her acting roles
right like that's why it never made
sense like there were no older Ro roles
for older women in Hollywood cuz it's
like well someone has to play the mom
and the
grandma true and it's like they would
have like a 35-year-old being someone's
Mom it's like come on nobody looks like
that yeah grow up literally literally
grow up like isn't acting supposed to be
accurate yeah but I guess like the point
is you know you play the mom or the
grandma and you're you know you're 35
playing the mom yeah and it's like
that's not the star you're just the mom
or the grandma yeah no I guess that
hasn't changed like there are roles for
older women but like bond is 60 has
there been a franchise made off of a
60-year-old woman yeah it's insane true
go off what what would the 60-year-old
woman franchise be I guess they were
trying to do that with like book club
and Brady for 80 80 for Brady yeah I
didn't see book club but I did see 80
for Brady and I lived to tell the tale I
did feel like a little bit compelled
like maybe two months ago to watch book
club it was like a Friday night we were
like going to rent a movie I keep going
to Apple to rent Oppenheimer and every
time I do it's not out yet it's always
available for pre-order so then like on
the list book club is always on there so
I'm like oh Oppenheimer no book club
maybe I've never felt compelled enough
to actually purchase but maybe you're
part of the
problem like your hesitancy is like why
movies like that don't do as well and
they don't keep making them because like
let me ask a question fair fair but let
me ask a fair question anybody who saw
book club is it good like I didn't hear
it was amazing
I like the concept like four and I love
books I love my book club for girlies
who are older you know they start a book
club and it changes like I love the
concept but was it good because 80 for
Brady wasn't I feel like book club was
good because they made two of them right
so that's always a good sign so I guess
book club is the bond for girls or like
Nancy
Meyers yes okay that's better Nancy
Myers needs to start a franchise yeah
like a bond like thing where it's just
kind of the same bonds aren't even
special like there's danger he gets a
mission he almost dies he [__] a girl
he lives to tell the tale Nancy Myers
needs to do like it's complicated like a
female
protagonist falling in love in a
beautiful home she's very wealthy like
the the structure never changes it's
just a new city or a new girl you know I
mean that's kind of what she does yeah
but it's not a franchise it's just
different movies I don't know why I'm
yelling I need to calm down you're
passionate about the aism and Holly
aism coupled with sexism yeah there's no
agism for men in Hollywood I mean like
George Clooney's never been richer more
successful or more famous red pit yeah
well it's also not just Hollywood it's
kind of just Society in general like as
men age they're more dignified right no
let's talk about that let's talk about
how like young girls not young girls but
like girls in their 30s and 40s and even
20s like find certain men in their 60s
extremely attractive and hot and I don't
see many 20 and 30y old boys is dating
60-year-old women well it's I feel like
it's happening more you do I don't know
like here and there younger men with
older women not
super
old like I don't think so it's just like
a Trope like we find older men hot and
we find older women like
old yeah do you think find them like
maternal do you think it also has to do
with financial
success maybe do you think young girls
find old men hot
old man hot who's not who doesn't have
money I'd like to take money out of old
man I'm I'm I'm really talking about May
it's as women you know continue to age
and like the generation of women who
were like Boss [__] successful get
older like they might find favor with
young men because they have money no I
really I want to take money out of it
because I'm really talking about like
attraction I'm talking about how like we
see like just now Patrick Dempsey with
man's like we all look at him we're like
oh my God he's hot like we would [__]
him like that's the that's sort of the
narrative and with like people's most
beautiful woman whatever let's say it's
like you know a 60-year-old Julia
Roberts like oh she's beautiful you know
like we talk about it differently yeah I
understand not like damn let me get in
there Julia like no I agree with her
you're saying and I understand I'm just
trying to get more to the root of it
aside from obviously just plain old
agism and sexism right which
exists but like Julia Roberts is Rich
yeah you don't see people like bursting
in her comments like come to Brazil
Julia yeah but like they're saying come
to Brazil
Patrick they are they are do you think
he's going to go to Brazil I do cool so
just I don't have any answers I'm just
asking questions it's important to ask
questions that's where we start it's a
start it's a start to ask the right
questions yeah are you ready for our
fifth and final story actually a perfect
story to sum up every conversation today
okay a biopic about an older woman is in
the works and it will be AI generated
what old just like a general older woman
no specific older woman oh okay why' you
say it like that because I'm trying to
get the themes oh okay okay AI a women
older okay Edith PE off AI generated
biopic is in the works at Warner Music
wait can I ask you a uh question who's
edth be you know Lan
rose that
song oh so she's a
singer no I know that song so that's
like her Legacy amongst other things but
like that's I probably so she was is she
American is she French I think she's
French she's a French
singer and why do we care about this
story cuz they're going to be using AI
oh oh I guess that does make it
interesting to recreate her boy an image
and it's a role for an older woman that
they're literally giving to a robot oh
my God it's a voice for an older woman
that they're literally giving to a robot
yeah Warner Music Group announced it has
partnered with PE offs estate for Edith
set to be a 90-minute film set in Paris
and New York from the 1920s to the 60s
you think the name Edith is going to
make a comeback soon it's a pretty name
I feel like it could I feel like it was
like like a World War II name like young
there were so many young girls named
Edith yeah like downtown yes yeah but
then then we started to think of it as
like an older lady name because all the
old the young ediths grew up into
grandmas yeah but you know what I also
realize it's like a lot of people
especially for I see this with Jews it's
like you name your children after people
grandparents or great-grandparents so
you wind up recycling those old names
that become young again yes that's like
Harry
yes so it's really quite cyclical
yeah back to AI there was a role there
was a role the film will be narrated by
Street the film will be narrated by an
AI I never know how to pronounce this
word and I don't know what it means fasy
smile you know the word what no F A
spell it f a c f need to write F I need
to write it f f a c e s no no F A CS i m
i l e
fascist smile okay wait F literally
never heard this word it means an exact
copy especially of written or printed
material now hold on let me
play and it's pronounced wait sh
faximile faimily faximile faim you learn
something new every day here faximile
faimily
faim I like I'm like Diplo literally
Diplo X Edith P off X fimile he'll do
the soundtrack for this
movie
yeah me closer let me
go this is
La I feel like that's so classic like
whenever like a Instagram girlly goes to
France and she like takes a picture of
the Eiffel Tower on her story she always
plays that song and she's like walking
from behind maybe like looking into a
shop someone's filming her from behind
and the Eiffel Tower is in front of her
and she like looks back at the camera
and like Twirls her hair yeah and is it
someone filming her or is it a
tripod the world may never
know okay let me get to Deep by the way
I have to say like I'm all for making
content out in the wild like I'm always
filming myself um in the back of cabs
like I don't give a [__] but it takes a
different kind of Beast to bring a
tripod out in public cuz when you have
no one to take pictures for you and you
use a little clicker and like it works
great and I to respect the Hustle but
like that's another level of commitment
but that's why like those girls who do
that they get the shot they get the
brands they get they
unabashedly and they're like they're
being successful they have what it takes
I respect it I respect it but it could
never be me agreed I can barely have my
husband take a picture of me without me
wanting to like cringe into myself and
be like forget it no it's fine forget it
forget it forget forget it so I'm
literally like take a picture of me I go
to take it and I'm like no stop it's
fine I got it no and then I grab the
phone back and I see that I'm like
forget it no it's like I I maybe got one
before I
cringed and it's obviously like not good
of and then it's like I'm mad he didn't
get a good picture of me but it's like I
couldn't unfurl myself this isn't going
to
work here are the Deets I feel like I
feel like that's just like enough you
know I feel like it's like better if we
actually don't get to the details I'm
going to finish this one sentence okay
okay okay the film will be narrated by
an AI generated fasy smile of what did
we say it
was of PE off's voice and Promises to
uncover aspects of her life that were
previously unknown classic chilling
chilling all right happy for Edith and
the whole family yeah but sad for the
older woman who lost out on this role
who this would have been a role of a
lifetime for of a
lifetime
Edith so that's our
show yeah and as predicted it was a
great one
the thing
is we knew it like we knew it I know but
we had to show everyone cuz we have some
doubters non-believers who said oh
Jackie sick the story's stink like how
are they going to make something today
and look what we did the doubters and
nonbeliever are always coming for us
before we end today's episode let me
just remind you to call your
representatives and tell them hashtag
yell is overp party and remind you that
toast chili merch is available at shop
toast merch.com we love you guys thank
you so much for listening to the to L
Morning Show where we deliver the past
life stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel fre to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
anywhere podcast can be found so Spotify
public radio all the places list to
podcast find usar view that a beautiful
standing and wickedly talented we are
love you love you bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye love you bye
bye